le cerf article est une des régions les
plus fragiles de notre planète
mais il est difficile de savoir combien
son écosystème est affecté par des
activités humaines
une équipe de l'université laval utilise
une méthode à la fine pointe de la
génétique pour tenter de percer ce
mystère
ces petits tubes remplis d'eau ont été
prélevés au large 10 cas 8 dans le
nunavut
ils sont remplis aussi de matériel
génétique toutes les espèces de l'océan
en laisse derrière elle des cellules
mortes des sécrétions des excréments
autant d'adr diluer dans l'eau c'est de
l'adn environnementales ou adn et une
mine d'informations de plus en plus
révélatrice grâce aux avancées des
sciences génétique
ces informations anaïs lacoursière
roussel et ses collègues de l'université
laval veulent les mettre à profit pour
étudier un des écosystèmes les moins
bien connus sur terre l'océan arctique
ce qu'on apprend a fait ses classes dans
un environnement pas les traces
génétiques sont de façon plus abondante
et diversifiée qu'on pouvait l'imaginer
et quelques années donc on peut
retrouver ses traces là de façon
beaucoup plus simple qu'on pense qu'on
croyait avec des petits volumes d'eau et
non seulement ça c'est qu'on se rend
compte qu'on connaît très peu sur la
diversité locale
anaïs et ses collègues de l'université
laval ont passé quatre ans à ramasser
des échantillons d'eau dans cinq ports
au nord du québec au nunavut et au
manitoba des lieux à proximité
d'activité industrielle qui pourrait
avoir un impact à long terme sur
l'écosystème
ce qu'on voulait voir en fait c'est non
seulement sont est capable de retracer
leur donne environnementale mais si ça
peut devenir une méthode efficace à très
grande échelle
pour ce faire les chercheurs se sont
associés aux communautés locales
ils leur ont fourni des trousses
d'échantillonnage individuelle et leur
montrer à les utiliser
les volontaires apprennent comment
récolter des échantillons et les faire
parvenir aux laboratoires
ils pourront ainsi faire un
échantillonnage récurrents et étendu ce
qui est difficile à obtenir dans
l'arctique au laboratoire de l'institut
de biologie intégrative et des systèmes
de l'université laval
les chercheurs isole et amplifie les
infimes traces d'adr contenu dans chaque
échantillon le séquenceur traduit tous
ces codes génétiques en code
informatique
il suffit ensuite d'associer chaque brin
d'un des haines à une espèce connue
avec moins de 15 litres d'eau on est
capable de trouver environ 150 espèces
et on sait que 150 autres à génétique
provient des organismes d un conte ne
pas la connaissance génomique pour
identifier les espèces donc en bois de
crise le dos dans un port commercial on
est capable de trouver environ 300
espèces pour identifier une espèce à
partir de son adn
les chercheurs doivent comparer cet adn
à celui qu'on trouve dans une banque de
données génomiques une sorte de
dictionnaire comme un des codes
génétiques des espèces
ce dictionnaire rassemble l'ensemble de
nos connaissances sur la génétique mais
il contient peu d'informations sur celle
des animaux marins arctiques
on retrouve des espèces emblématiques
comme le béluga et surtout une variété
impressionnante de petits annélides de
bonus que et d'arthropodes la moitié des
espèces échantillonnés ne peuvent pas
être identifiés mais ce n'est qu'une
question de temps
[Musique]
les chercheurs du monde entier ajoute
sans cesse de nouvelles espèces au
dictionnaire un échantillon d'adn et n1
recueillies aujourd'hui pour être
réinterprété plus tard donc surtout ces
traces génétiques ne peuvent être suivis
au cours du temps même si on n'a pas
d'informations spécifiques sur l'espèce
on qu'on a comme une longueur d'avancé
on a conçu une connaissance en
enregistrant ses banques de données de
séquençage
même s'ils ne peuvent pas identifier
toutes les espèces recensées les
chercheurs peuvent en déterminer le
nombre et même la famille à laquelle
elle appartient
ce sont de précieux indices sur la santé
de l'écosystème pour savoir s'il ya une
perte de biodiversité
les chercheurs doivent pouvoir comparer
les échantillons au cours du temps
et marées la coopérative les saisons de
nombreux facteurs peuvent faire varier
des quantités d adn dans l'océan
arctique
l'équipe de l'université laval est l'une
des premières à s'y intéresser
lorsque l'adn libéré par les organismes
ensuite est là elle est affectée par
l'écologie de l'eau donne
environnementale
donc elle peut être transporté elle peut
se dégrader différentes aux dégradations
donc c'est ce comportement là des
molécules dans l'eau qui nous intéresse
pour finalement réussir à venir comparé
des échantillons de dien
environnementale au cours du temps et
donc mettre en relief certains derrière
son biodiversité l'océan arctique se
réchauffe plus rapidement que le reste
de la planète
il est difficile de savoir quel effet
cela aura sur la biodiversité car on la
connait trés deux des chercheurs
estiment qu entre 28 et 33 % des espèces
dans l'océan arctique canadien n'ont pas
encore été découverte
beaucoup d'espoir pour les chercheurs
comme anaïs la course et à roussel qui
veulent découvrir ce qui se cache encore
dans cette immense masse tôt
[Musique]